hey guys how's it going so I am off to
San Francisco right now and this is mmm
whoops my original flight was supposed
to be at 10:30 and it is now 12:30 p.m.
last night we were shooting so many
cooking videos and I was so exhausted
that I woke up this morning also there's
no possible way that I can physically
get up go to the airport and make this
slight on time so thankfully Southwest
is amazing not sponsored but you can
just change your flight and they don't
really give you a penalty so I changed
my flight my back to bed for two hours
and then clean my kitchen which
surprisingly it cleaned up quite nicely
you guys don't even know the mess like
I'm just gonna just wow wait for
Valentine's Day and st. Patrick's Day
cooking videos and you'll see what has
happened there's still some icing on the
floor well I guess outside the airport
now that it's time for my actual flight
[Music]
the airport and since I got a house like
I need a coffee so bad as I waited
forever because they just made a fresh
pot of it and as I'm walking I spilled
it all over myself
[Music]
[Applause]
let's do a hotel room tour here's the
shower it's like a nice little bathroom
plenty of room oh here's my office it's
a nice view of nothing oh look at that
just making sure my outfit is on fleek
[Music]
what's gonna go down tonight will be
over is sleeping quarters right so for
some context is Who I am pretty shocked
uh there's nothing wrong with this room
it's clean it's nice but I think it got
tricked because these are the photos
that I saw online and this is this is
reality expectation reality this is a
very unique design but definitely not
what I signed up for and not even that
oh I left my camera in the uber
obviously I'm vlogging on it right now
so I got it back so thank you very very
kind of a person for returning my camera
to me because if you had it this blog
wouldn't even be happening because it
wouldn't have a camera and all the
footage I shot this morning wouldn't
even be ever seen by you guys go into
the bathroom bringing a bowl my stuff
here we are
[Music]
some of you guys might be new to my
channel probably don't know that I made
some of my first Apple store videos that
I moved to California in a San Francisco
Apple store and right in front of me is
one of the brand new Apple stores here
in SF and it is oh my goodness it's so
beautiful it has an incredible open
front design like the entire front of it
is glass it's two stories this thing
looks just oh my god guys I'm having a
moment okay I'm gonna go in and I'm
switch to vlogging on my phone so here
goes
[Music]
surveys my emotions are running very
high right now and people are watching
me vlog obviously because you look silly
vlogging no matter how many times how
many years you've been doing it
look at these upstairs
this is incredible they have this whole
open floor there are actual real trees
here that people can sit and enjoy the
outdoors but yet indoors
I just want to sit I'm gonna say
this is so cool
okay let's go see on the other side the
screen is massive this is something that
I need in my house I basically just want
to make this building my house
like a nice little outdoor patio I can
come out here and I can enjoy the
outside but yet the outside is inside
so it looks like you can enter this
store from either the front or the back
and the back is actually the second
floor so right now we are up here
all is a covering name
oh my god it's so far this is probably
one of my favorite Apple stores so that
I've ever been into it's perfect
let's see if I can find something to buy
something that I do I definitely need is
a new dongle because my sister broke
mine she put it into her computer and
then she dropped her computer and then
it bent USB C port so I don't have an SD
card reader right now so that's gonna
prove to be a problem this isn't
vlogging on my iPhone but I really need
one cuz I can just drop everything go to
my computer look at these these are very
nice
okay well they don't have any USBC card
readers so yes I'm gonna leave now but I
just wanted to show you guys the store
because I've been wanting to visit it
for a really really long time and I've
been waiting very very patiently for it
so here it is and it's it is stunning
what else and we're going to be doing
that
you know 6:00 p.m. after you started
really smart Oh No
I'm so sad I walk all the way down here
is so excited it's like Oh creepy the
museum closes at 11:00 well guess what
they're having a private event today so
I can't go so now I guess we'll just
find somewhere to eat dinner
bleh my iPhone game
[Music]
this game that's called the last day on
earth and I a hundred percent have to
blame Nick because who's playing it all
to see yes but they're playing a game
Wow
I'm eating dinner and this restaurant
[Music]
Valley long time yes I've had a meal
that is missing particles one of things
I love ostentatious Cove is incredibly
this is so big I'm having an incredible
meal
is so addictive this is that
it's strung it up a lot oh no I died
I just looted my own body so this is
desert these are like doughnut beignet
with chocolate and caramel and then they
give me ice cream and just an added
bonus
a lot of desert for just myself not even
look at it like my stomach is so full an
amazing dinner
finish eating some dessert and then they
brought me another tiny mini dessert
this is overwhelming a mini dessert look
at the little mini this is something
that I should definitely try to make it
a feature video it's mini macaroons this
is you
[Music]
I'm back I'm out of breath because I was
like you know what I just ate so many
desserts and so much delicious food take
the steps just Ain take the steps and
Wow
the steps I took now let it go up more
steps to get ready to read the brush my
teeth so this hotel is still so
interesting to me I've never stayed in
such a random hotel room like this it
feels like it's pretty newly renovated
because everything is clean and they
feel like maybe they're missing a few
things maybe I can help them out of
there let's hide this that's will okay
this is gonna change the whole feel of
the room helping a chord management well
have a bunch of meetings tomorrow and
then I'm heading back to LA I'm hoping
that depending upon where my flight is
and when I get done with my meeting is
that I will be able to go to the Art
Museum since I didn't get to tonight I
was so excited to go I've never been
even the living in San Francisco I can't
believe I've never actually gone but
today was gonna be the day maybe today
just wasn't my day
judging by the my things they went wrong
today just the things that I've
documented on camera for you it feels
like Monday it but it's definitely not
it's just one of those days
[Music]